cafe bar D place is in deep trouble in
the last year food sales have dropped
7,000 pounds a week and depressed Li
since I arrived I found few positives to
build on
it's time for Israel to pull his head
out the sand and smell the coffee
looking the situation I can actually
confirm I'm [ __ ] myself I'm worried
about the situation in the kitchen the
idea cooking there's not a lot going on
in there no the standard it's pretty
crap and what I have identified lately
is lack of pride yeah and a huge lack of
respect to many individuals like you've
got now you're completely [ __ ]
business but have you no real business
no no sense of pride for the business it
starts from the top you have to stay
[ __ ] strong on top of it because
without your determination
and we need to turn their attitudes
around get their heads out there are
souls and [ __ ] get this place back on
track the animosity between Dave and
Phillip is dragging the business down
there like a whinging old couple so on
day three it's time to start building
bridges with some tried and tested
marriage guidance tactics hi aunt
so whilst you've got that egg in your
hand tell Dave what you're really
thinking about it well they's you're
just an arrogant little bastard you know
you think you know everything you're the
most beautiful you the most perfect guy
there is that's the bottom line and I
think you can have your arse on you
because when I do try and talk to you
these if I do shout it's because you
argue and don't let me finish so from
now on stop being a stubborn [ __ ]
French bastard because we're not gonna
work it so when this place is gonna go
down there's nothing that that would
like more than actually being able to
work with the manager of the restaurant
this whole exercise is not personal it's
about business and do your [ __ ] jobs
I just beg you both to continue talking
to
because that hasn't taken place
understand each other's jobs I'll shake
hands
for the better it's not just Phil's
relationship with Dave that's boring me
he seems to have lost any real command
of his kitchen an efficient brigade
flies on constant motivation from their
head chef
but Munya and Alma are left to fester in
bottle sauces and frozen deep fried food
they're picking up one bad habit after
another and Phillip doesn't even seem to
care not a French omelet
okay holy mackerel
show me it's time to find out what
happened to Philly blaze executive chef
extraordinaire I see a man in front of
me at 40 years of age French that had
bloody good jobs before at the executive
[ __ ] level whether it's bel go or
Planet Hollywood but I don't see
anything that resembles a chef if you
are buying so much food in and it's
making you look [ __ ] yeah why are you
fighting against that chefs fight for
reputations and show the hunger to the
customers of making them happy it's true
up to a point yes I may have given out
because they see that this thank-oo but
I am still as hungry as I was to
actually do and create things okay well
I want to help you and I want to work
closely with you to get things back on
line just to install that little bit of
[ __ ]
normality pride you just said it get it
back